sometimes that happens you know what you
know what i did want to ask you because
i think you two are similar in this
sense where you were doing a very family
friendly show and you guys are both very
dirty filthy comedians we're not i don't
think we're dirty filthy i think we're
earnest and fun and we don't care about
we don't edit we're we're right it's not
the same audience though that's watching
it it is now for when i go to stand up
now it's the people that watch it can't
be the kids right but it it's their
parents they grew up watching full house
that understand me now it only took me
40 years but right but and you were
doing that before full house i was doing
it not as blue but near the right before
i got full house i'd done
more blue stuff before i hit 30 years
old when i got full house so i from 26
to 30 i was dropping more f-bombs i was
out touring more and uh and then once i
got the show and then i would go do
stand-up with america's funny son videos
and full house on the air and they
couldn't figure out what the hell was
going on well that even happens to me
now you know with agt you know which is
a good i'm sure you have that is there a
cure
that's like uh
how do you get an agt you get it from uh
afv
we both had that
those are our stds i had af hv because
it was america's funniest home videos
and oh wow the h
and then it became afv so it all sounds
like it's something you gotta tend to
the cdc yeah i identify as somebody from
agt so
but i'll go do my shows like maybe in a
casino or something and there's always
somebody walking out holding the hand of
a little kid going what is this what is
this right you're not like this on tv
yeah you know and i feel bad i apologize
i go but you know i've been doing
stand-up for 42 years i've been doing
agt for
nine you know i get it you know it's
funny you're talking about talking with
my around my daughter like that in our
house she wasn't even allowed to say
shut up right we were very respectful in
the house but now you're an adult and
you can hear
who stopped her from saying shut up you
or terry no he was the disciplinarian he
was really strict wow isn't that amazing
i don't even see you that way i know but
you're not my daughter dude i want to be
you know we had no you don't no no no i
haven't you hit her no no but i had to
eat her
mentally she she uh was a really rough
kid from we've talked about that before
but you were really rough from 14 to 21.
it was horrible that could happen and i
thought i was going to die
right and not just daughters right i
have three yeah three 34 31 28. were
they hard uh a couple of them through
times and they've also had their own
difficulties that they've
they've understood and uh you know
therapy helps yeah helped me she's still
in it it's uh i i don't see a reason to
get out of it unless you feel like i
don't need it right now it's good to
figure out and process your life is what
i think especially if your dad uh was
very a hard disciplinarian and yet for
the rest of the world he was
being silly and adorable yeah but my my
persona ogre was i know
at times well you would lie you know
you would lie
i didn't lie that was the problem i
should have lied more i told you
everything
yeah wait a minute it was hard but she
told you oh she said what you said no
like i i went into her room and i found
a bottle a half
drunken bottle of gin i've i've done
that before so i pulled it in my own
room
but what was your answer when i went
jackie what is this i said it's not mine
i only drink vodka
so
how did it get there no no but the fact
that she said i finished all my bottles
and i threw them out she drank her vodka
she was drunk you know or she went and
got but it wasn't vodka
so you were lying about this oh she had
friends over people were sneaking away
and that's what i'm saying was she
wasn't lying it was another person's
booze
i could have just stopped well i'm
interested because i've had this issue
when my dog when one of my daughters was
16 she had a bunch of friends sleep over
and that was um you know
they always say nothing good happens
after midnight uh so i would say okay
you guys could stay here you'll be at my
house and we were
we were divorced when she was seven this
particular daughter and uh the other
ones were different ages
that's nice makes divorce much more
palatable but uh but her friends were
there and they're up all night partying
i don't know what they were doing and i
wanted to stay out of it i just was glad
they were home
but um yeah you find stuff i one of my
daughters had a party and i i wasn't
home
and it started to escalate and then the
next day i found bottles of booze and i
found some condom wrappers and i was
like what inside of my house what
that was
i know well welcome to the world she was
hanging out they were my condom rappers
by the way i wasn't at the party i was
just upset you were at the side of the
house listening right yeah you had to go
purchase more
yeah well i just get them free yeah you
know because i'm like yeah because it's
a celebrity yeah it's like a hair club
for men i bought the company uh but her
uh we uh i was it was
horrible i don't know what if i wanted
like she was hanging out with there were
three movies made about her time in
school
uh one being the um uh what's the justin
timberlake movie the dog alpha dog she
was i was gonna really i was gonna go
mean girls but no you're talking real no
real the kid was she knows a lot of kids
that were killed
she knows
just bad
bad people and i can't tell you how many
times i walked into a party where she
wasn't supposed to be and physically
dragged her out that's a good dad though
yeah no i appreciate it now
but then you were furious i hated it
well this thing is she pierced her
tongue at 15 by yourself
no but i said i did it by myself because
i didn't want to get the piercing place
in trouble so
he protected a piercing place
come here she's always got how dare you
and you know it was her mom was really
upset and she had asked whether she
could have her tongue pierced before and
yeah and her mom had said no i didn't it
didn't bother me as much i had my own
piercings and i had earrings right right
every time that's the hypocritical part
but you didn't have your tongue pierced
no but she uh was talking to us one
night and we heard this horrible
clicking
and you know so then she opened her
mouth and we saw that and
what you know then which i tried
leaf on my tongue the tongue piercing
yeah it was a pot was it pinned down by
the by the
piercing
it was like the a ball and inside the
ball was a picture of a
pot leaf a marijuana leaf that's
beautiful for your 15 year old little
girl comes home and goes hi dad it was a
little click on her teeth right so
um she could have been a percussionist
an oral percussionist so i said you know
listen
you asked your mother your mother said
no she goes it's my body i can do what i
want and i said you can yeah
you can and then i said uh you know uh
well you know it's our house we can do
what we want and you seem to be uh we're
giving you gifts you know she drove a
car she had a car at 15 she got a car
that she was learning to drive on she
just turned 16 when this happened so she
was driving and i go i can't reward you
for this kind of behavior
so i i'm not
it is your body but you don't have a car
anymore she goes well how am i going to
get places i said i will drive you
everywhere so first
i said and at such time that you decide
you want to listen to me and take it out
i'll give you back the keys so for six
months every morning i got up and drove
her to school drove her to parties and
it was the most annoying she would blast
the worst [ __ ] music i've ever heard
in my life and sing along and i will say
this
singing is not her strong suit
no she's horrible well it's because you
she she pierced her tongue that throws
your vocal cords right
is that what it was and then after six
months she finally handed me the little
pot leaf and i handed her the keys and
the rest
really you gave in and gave it to him
yeah yeah how did you feel about that
did you not want to do it did you feel
like you gave up your independence and
that he was unfair because there is
there are two sides to that story really
well you're taking her side no no
because i think you're just like a cool
dad no i'm not i'm not i'm not i but
your discipline over i appreciate a lot
because i think a lot of people uh
especially people that are fortunate
don't really discipline their kids
meaning not discipline the idea is
guidance right the idea is so that they
don't end up well i was in therapy who
told me you know that if i want to get
not my way but if i want to
create a path i can't lower myself to
her level and i'd already removed
everything from her room including her
door
yeah i didn't have a door
that's kind of
cool no it is because you really did
have a problem it sounds like you did do
you think you had a problem from what
from removing a door don't you think
that would mean
did it get your attention did you go
wait a minute this is real i i have been
off the rails
no not the removing the door part it
just kept going so no it took a lot more
did you take the walls down
no i just moved out i went to college
and then i realized like i was in the
wrong and i had a good and i was being a
little
you could say you could say bad words in
front of me yeah i was being a brat
right she was being a cabrette yeah yeah
i'll tell you i had a similar situation
with uh my middle daughter um and she's
now 31 and she's they're all you know
you love them so much you people say who
do you love best you know who it is it's
one but uh no
it's whoever you're with at the moment
usually if right if things are good i'm
with you bob
oh that's i'm so glad you moved the
camera for my reaction
my reaction was so sincere you would
have never seen it with the camera no it
would have been like wow they see a lot
of the clips so my my middle daughter
was uh just got her license and uh she
got a ticket that day and then said and
she wasn't supposed to drive other
passengers because she just got it
there's a six month time
and she was in a parking lot and there
were other guys there and people were
stoned i didn't know the whole deal
about it and she wanted to help jump
another person's car so her car doors
were open and they two guys that were
stoned started to put the car in neutral
her car that was my car and it started
to back up and it scratched the whole
side of another car and it also bent the
door on her car and she already got a
ticket right so i didn't want it to go
on a record so i paid cash to the person
whose car was damaged and i paid cash to
fix her car which was you know i was
like four grand that's what i was and i
said you're getting a job you're gonna
pay for this right and um
and then i beat her no i said yeah i
didn't and she worked at coldstones and
i was a manager at coldstone well done
yeah for my daughter
how long did you do that how long i
don't know two years two something like
that and that happened because
no i always loved working well you also
had a uh
didn't you like the manager i had a
boyfriend at coldstone that worked oh
this is this this is all coming together
now did you sing the song when it was uh
yeah when they tipped well yeah what's
the tip song
there's a bunch of them but you remember
them hi ho hi ho we thank you for your
dough we come to work and play all day
hi ho hi ho hi ho hi ho
we're cheerful and we're holler because
we got a dollar we're thankful because
we all are the coldstone family done in
a nut oh my god my daughter rebelled to
all of that so she would wear a hat and
she hated singing the song she refused
to sing
i loved that tip and she would just be
their
cold stone face
and my youngest daughter and i would
pull up and i would give my youngest a
20
and tell her to run in and we wouldn't
buy anything i'll be waiting the car
outside because i wasn't allowed to go
in
but she was being punished that's why
she worked there because she needed to
pay off this debt right and my daughter
put 20
in my little one who put it in the tip
jar dipped can trash can a swinging
trash can and then run back in the car
giggling and we had to watch her through
the window and she looked at us with
eyes
we love you [ __ ] father she moved her
mouth like a puppet
she hated it and then she was she was
going to work there another month and i
let her out when she was like six
hundred dollars under the full
four thousand dollar payment so i said
it's enough i i can't watch this anymore
that's funny and the torture children
are so much fun to torture
[Music]